you
let's try it again Pond Island we
haven't played yet have we no what I
hear shows right here we haven't played
yet so king of the hill let me establish
a pond in the center space in the center
is a big deal so I don't want him
getting any crazy ideas going towards
the center these can turn quite mmm much
like regular chests these king of the
hill games yeah let's go here not so
quick to castle in these king of the
hill games so this is a good idea to
remove this pond is to remove White's
control over a five and you're just
three moves away in some cases from
winning it
I may be alright with just allowing this
capture because it places a grip over
that I think I am on ok with that
let's see Queens off the board your king
wants to pretty much stay in the center
let's see okay well I could force Bishop
takes pawn or Bishop takes Bishop with
c4 no rush just yeah I don't think yeah
let's just do this Knight d2 then I'll
do this and there now I really want to
like just recapture on the square with
my king at some point like here Bishop
takes King takes and kind of scoop my
king up here because I have some space
well space with this guy just his
presence alone but also due to my
control over this a deeper square and
White's position on e4 and yeah has been
a while for the king of the hill game
and the games that I did play last with
this variant where bullet games so it's
it's nice to actually devote some time
to to thinking here with this variant
that seems kind of slow I
on a castle I'm gonna go in for this and
I am prepared to take with my king yep
I'm gonna keep him two steps away from
maybe any of these two squares also if
this Knight is captured I'm gonna take
with this pawn because it provides a new
possibility for my king
so that said maybe they're ready to like
take here and if I do that they take
here
Oh though maybe that's not so bad of a
gambit they can't push my knight away
because of this should I move my king up
right now or is that getting a little
bit too crazy I am going to I'm gonna
just develop my queen yeah I really just
don't want this pawn here maybe I give
that up it might be alright like night
here pawn takes okay what do they got
wind up should I move my king up one
let's just stop that pond from going any
further for a moment not quite sure what
their idea is here no let's just do that
okay so that was their idea they just
wanted to get rid of my knight all along
let's take here I don't want to take
here and invite their king forward a
rank so get your king here and you're
gonna win huh
let's get opposite their king I could go
over here you know things are a little
bit scary my king is two steps away
their King is still three this should be
an advantage for me if I could remove
this pawn that would be great let's just
stop that rook takes pawn yeah I want
the Queen's off and I want to put my
king right here these sacrifices are
only helping me open up the d5 square
okay their King is creeping a little bit
closer let's go here which stops this
break because I could take and the pawn
is pinched their king so I want to get
my king here and then maybe they're set
all they're going in for that okay this
is king of the hill not queen of the
hill maybe that's their their big plan
King right here rook takes Queen King
takes rook mate
okay this square is open up I think I'm
winning now that they might have to do
something like this to stop my king from
getting here this is my only fear really
King III but I play Queen here control
this square I have this square under
control also this is stopping rook here
need to control this square my queen has
it and I'm going to win now because I
could take here with check they can't
take with their King and next I play
King here just in time for mate king of
the hill style and they resigned alright
that was a good game
that was that was neat I had that space
advantage slight you know having control
over efore right here and this has c4
upon a little bit of a cramp
being effect there against white and I
was really wanting to see the capture of
my night because I would have strongly
considered capturing with my deep on
although it would cost upon it would
open up a new square for my King
together to get in there king of the
hill style
alright let's some ji-ji-ji to an island
you